The Citadel has a new business model
but could that be a business model that
would also be perfect for Stargate
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so what is this business
so a lot of people have done a couple of
videos recently actually saying that
Amazon is awful Jennifer sulky is awful
and that you know everything they touch
is rubbish now that just isn't true but
a lot of them are actually using this
Citadel as an example of why Amazon
keeps failing that this 250 million
dollar TV series was a complete flop the
problem is that's not true fair enough
it didn't do very well in the United
States but internationally it did very
very well thank you very much
particularly in India this show
did very well and that is pushing Amazon
Prime's International growth something
it's very very interested in doing
now at the moment we're seeing a bunch
of strikes over at Hollywood strikes
that we need to 100 get behind because
we want Hollywood to stay relevant but
we also want these actors and these
writers to get a deal that is really
really fair
please go and support the actors you
love the writers you love The Producers
Etc because the TV shows that you love
really are at risk right now so please
go and give them your support
but what is this international business
model that the Citadel TV show is taking
on well the idea basically is that
you've got the core TV show The Citadel
TV show that's based code of in the west
but then because this is a spy Network
as offices all over the world you can
then have TV shows that are set all over
the world think about how CSI had CSI
Vegas CSI Miami CSI New York now put
that on a worldwide stage you can have
Citadel Delhi Citadel Melbourne Citadel
London
Etc TV shows that are set
internationally but most importantly
within the same universe
so that these TV shows could actually
influence each other they could actually
affect each other and actually create a
much wider universe
but as well Create TV shows specifically
for the audiences they're in now I spoke
about this on a live the other day and
most people actually did virtually
immediately say look this is a great
idea but they have to speak English the
shows must be in English and I actually
think widely they will be there are a
lot of people in China that speak
English there's a lot of people in India
that speak English English is pretty
much the most spoken language on the
planet but it would also be really
brilliant for these shows to have their
native tongs in as well that you know
they actually speak to each other in
their native language but speak to in
English when it makes sense to I'm
thinking a little bit like Firefly how
they would flip between the two if done
cleverly we could still watch it in the
west okay some bits might have to be
subtitled I don't really like reading my
television but if the TV shows were done
to a high enough standard I'd watch them
so why is this happening right now well
Hollywood isn't the you know main
Kingpin of the entertainment business
anymore
Bollywood has been probably wealthier
than Hollywood for quite a long time
China has a reasonably good Studio
business even though there is a law that
basically says you can't do anything
that embarrasses the government of China
so you know Limited
Golden Harvest used to make amazing
movies coming out of Hong Kong and
afraid that doesn't happen anymore now
Jenny stiven was actually talking about
this on the dial the gate video a couple
of days ago she was actually talking
about a really amazing production Center
in Nigeria where actually they do speak
English and they are producing some
really incredible TV shows Netflix has
actually been really promoting this idea
for ages by putting TV shows from around
the world internationally on to Netflix
South Korea etc etc Netflix have
actually recently invested massively
into South Korea and trying to bring six
brand new TV shows through so this
really isn't a new plan by Amazon but by
doing this International Citadel that is
a little bit different and brave now I
spoke to somebody that I know Works um
in and around advertising they actually
work around development so his job
basically is to develop new markets for
certain projects now he said that think
about the car industry now give me a
minute I am going somewhere with this
but he basically was arguing that BMW
Mercedes Ford Etc have been desperately
trying to break into the Indian and
Chinese markets now they've been able to
do that to a degree over the last few
years basically because their product
was always superior BMW builds a better
product than any Chinese or Indian
manufacturer possibly could their cars
are just better
now Hollywood has been producing movies
and television that was just better than
anything Bollywood China anywhere else
in the world could produce
but the Gap is shrinking in the car
industry suddenly Chinese manufacturers
are building cars that are nearly as
good
some case just as good but they're
building them cheaper
all of a sudden the gap between the
Western companies and what they're doing
in India China Etc has shrunk
and all of a sudden the product isn't
better Hollywood has this issue that
they are just producing television
movies now around the world that are
just as good in quality as anything they
can do in Hollywood so very quickly
Hollywood is becoming irrelevant just
like the Western car manufacturers are
struggling to get into these new markets
of China India Etc really the entire
world
so is Hollywood the rest of the world
has a disposable income that they just
didn't have before they have Broadband
they have Cinemas they have everything
that we take for granted in the west
we're desperately trying to push into
these new markets and we're struggling
this Amazon Citadel model is really that
personified this is them desperately
trying to get into those markets by
using those markets and they already
have a way in in a recent video I told
you about how Amazon has its Studio
headquarters at Culver Studios but they
don't actually own the buildings the
buildings were constructed for them
especially by the owners they actually
have a couple of Studios there now as
well the owners are the Hackman group
now 10 or 15 years ago the Hackman group
was unknown in the entertainment
business but now they're one of the
largest independent owners of studios in
the world they produce already content
for almost every Studio on the planet
the Hackman group are enormous and
Amazon are already in bed with them but
why do I talk about this in relation to
Stargate well it seems to me that
Stargate is actually another TV show a
little bit like the Citadel that is
perfectly placed to take advantage of
the same thing basically you would have
the Stargate TV show because there's
only one Stargate okay we're gonna have
one star game the planet you can't have
more than one so the franchise would
center around that base wherever the
Stargate is now that's where the main
show would be but
the Russians have a BC 304 they probably
have a 305 or 306 by now the Chinese had
one
who else would have one you could easily
very easily have a BC 306 TV show based
aboard the Starship but it's a Chinese
Starship or an Indian Starship they have
a space program you or you could have a
TV show that's actually set wherever the
Stargate base is now it's not
necessarily still in America we don't
know that it could be on a neutral site
somewhere on the planet it could be at
the alpha site you know it could be
based on the moon or something
we don't know
but it could be a TV show that's just
based around the first SG Indian team we
don't know there's there's so many
possibilities for Stargate because it is
an international TV show it is supposed
to be the entire world together
so it would be very easy to get Stargate
International we could then get a lot
more Stargate though because think about
it it would be Indian production
companies making the show producing the
show everything it would potentially
influence and still you know be part of
the wider universe
but we could get more of the Stargate
hopefully in the same sort of quality
level because those shows could be
filming in conjunction with these
budgets don't matter because the budgets
would be separated the show would be
primarily made for the market it was
produced in but hopefully with enough
English with enough again high quality
Etc then it would still be really
interesting for us
they could have crossover episodes very
very easily a team from India again that
the main show is set in India based in
India blah blah blah could come to
California and go on a mission about
whatever
I would also then think that the movies
that we think we're also going to get
could then act as focal points for all
these TV series all of these different
TV series building up to a movie say
every three years or so there's so many
different possibilities that I think as
a Creator you would just salivate at it
you would just be desperate to get stuck
in but there is a risk and I think there
is a problem with this that actually it
could become too big
you would have to have somebody
somewhere that was making sure all of
this still made sense that all of the
universe still lined up
that Canon wasn't messed with that a
Creator in Indy didn't go on often
completely different tangent they would
have to be stargate's version of Kevin
FEI they would have to be somebody that
was keeping all of this in line and I'm
just hoping that if Amazon are thinking
along these lines which they might be
you know we've heard rumors for a long
time now that they want Stargate to be
really a tentpole project
they want to maybe do like a Marvel
style Big Universe franchise with
Stargate
then doing it internationally is a very
easy
cost-effective and quite exciting way to
do it
but I'd love to know what you think
because this idea could be very very
controversial and I have to say again
that this idea basically is Jenny
Steven's idea
um she spoke about this and alligator
I've never heard of this sort of theory
before it's a brilliant idea and I give
her maximum credit for it I'd love to
know though what you think as well as I
say this could be controversial
I'd love to know so get into the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first and for a
small contribution each month that
really supports the channel you get to
see it without the adverts and you get a
free gift after three months everyone's
a winner
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
thank you